[Musik]
für das fahrrad das leben lohn bekommen
und ein sehr gutes praktikumszeugnis war
glückwunsch gut gemacht danke ich habe
mir überlegt ich möchte weiter beim film
arbeiten ok ich könnte schauspieler
werden es gibt ziemlich gute
schauspielschulen hier in deutschland
stoppen
hast du dir das gut überlegt na ja es
macht mir spaß ich habe einen freund der
schauspieler ist er ist sogar ziemlich
berühmt und hat für eine rolle mal einen
filmpreis gewonnen
ja und seit einem jahr hat er keine
aufträge mehr
[Musik]
die meisten schauspieler verdienen so
wenig geld dass sie mehrere jobs machen
müssen
ich unterstütze dich nico wenn es das
ist was du willst dann kriegen wir das
hin
aber ist es das was du willst